today i'm going to be speaking with
jamal greene who teaches constitutional
law
at columbia university and also is
author of
how rights went wrong why our obsession
with rights
is tearing america apart it's so great
to have you on i appreciate it
good to be here thanks so maybe just to
frame our conversation you know one of
the things
i've talked about over the last few
years is that a lot of these movements
that um claim to be or are ostensibly
about rights and about uh staking a
claim to a right
exercising a certain right they seem to
do this in the absence of an
understanding that with rights come
responsibilities and that the claiming
of rights in a vacuum seems to be
untenable and in some cases an
impossibility sort of in modern modern
society i'd love to kind of first hear
your thoughts a little bit about that
and the idea of
are right something that we should be
exploring
in a vacuum absent any cultural societal
reality
or is that context absolutely crucial to
thinking about rights
well i certainly think that rights are
embedded within a society
and and we actually have a very long
tradition in the united states
of thinking about rights and their
limits as something that
is a collective exercise that's actually
how the framers thought about rights but
we've gone away from that
vision and gotten to a place where
and i think this is where your political
movements come in
we tend to to use rights as political
leverage
because we tend to think about them in
almost absolute terms as as you say in a
vacuum kind of disconnected from all
else
that once you claim a right then you get
to win right so the whole game
becomes can i claim a right can i get
relevant decision makers um sometimes
courts
to to say that i have a right and that's
what's going to win me
my political battle and we i think we
need to get back to thinking about
rights
in political terms which is to say in
terms of
of being part of a society what is a
framework where we can think about
situations where rights
seemingly conflict or when we're talking
about
one's freedom or right to do something
versus someone else's freedom or right
to be free of that something what what's
the framework that we should be applying
to those conflicts
well one of the things i emphasize in
the book is that rights
inherently conflict they always conflict
and you can if you think about your
right to form a society and to pass laws
right so government
is is designed to protect rights and
there's also of course another side
where there's individuals who are
claiming
particular rights against what
government does so there's constantly
conflict
you've got to have a strategy for
managing that conflict
in the us our legal system has developed
to a place where
the way we the way we manage it is to
kind of pretend it doesn't exist pretend
the conflict isn't there
and that one side is right and the other
side is wrong so you got to pick who has
the right in any particular case
whereas in actually many other countries
in fact most other countries
the way in which the legal system tends
to respond is through i'll use a
legalistic term called proportionality
but what it really means
is that you kind of background
the question of who has the right you
just assume that rights exist
on both sides of a lot of legal
questions and you focus much more
heavily on what is the government doing
what kind of problem is it trying to
respond to
what kind of evidence is it relying on
what kind of alternatives are available
to it
is it acting totally disproportionately
or is it acting basically reasonably
those are the kinds of questions that we
typically ask when we're asking about
is this just is this fair um and those
questions are totally consistent with
the
the notion that uh that their rights
involved uh because you've gotta
what i say in the book is mediate
between different claims of rights on
multiple sides of a conflict and get at
really factual questions of what's
what's actually going on here we don't
need to to get into kind of a
legalistic questions of what does the
first amendment mean or what does the
constitution say those questions don't
get us very far
in answering questions about rights
conflicts we've got to get into the
into the factual details so i mean to
take a case maybe many in my audience
will be familiar with this infamous
gay wedding cake case from from the
state of colorado
one interpretation of that would be that
it's a question of
the right of a business owner to make
decisions
about how they want to operate their
business and the right
of the couple wanting the cake not to be
discriminated against on the basis of
sexual orientation
it might it could be framed as a right
versus a right
all sorts of different participants have
reframed it
where there's other ways to to think
about it
one could say well it's a judge or jury
choosing as to which whose rights reign
supreme but is it not that simple
i think it's not that simple and it's a
it's a fascinating case because i think
it really does
kind of burrow down on this on this
problem where i actually think there's
even more than two um sets of rights
involved so there's the rights of a
baker who wants to
to decide which which weddings he bakes
cakes for right and he's claiming a
religious right and also a free speech
right because his cakes are really
artistic so he
right he thinks that it's a way of
speaking there's the right of the couple
to not be discriminated against as you
say david
uh and then there's the right of the
people of colorado passed a law that
says don't discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation so
they've got right too at least the way i
frame it so there's rights on all sides
and you could think of it
in the most kind of binary terms as
a judge or jury's got to pick you know
whose rights count
but there actually are a lot
lots of overlap in how each of the sides
in that case understood the rights of
the other side
so the couple actually believed that a
a baker can choose whether to bake a
cake for someone he ideologically
disagrees with he can decide not to bake
a cake the couple agreed with that
the baker agreed that he actually can't
discriminate on the basis of sexual
orientation
uh in in baking his cakes he didn't
claim a first amendment right to avoid
discrimination
what the disagreement was was a much
more narrow disagreement
about whether refusing to bake a cake
for a same-sex wedding
counted as as as discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation
because the baker said i don't care who
my customers are i just don't want to
participate in this wedding and so
that's an ideological
dispute according to him he's not
actually discriminating against any
people
and the couple said well no if this had
been a a
opposite sex wedding you would have you
would have baked the cake and so that is
discrimination but that's actually a
pretty narrow
conflict and what i'm trying to suggest
in the book is that judges really
need to focus on on the narrow
part of the conflict rather than trying
to decide you know do we care more about
religious freedom or do we care more
about
equality for same-sex couples those are
values conflicts that we're not going to
resolve in a court case and
shouldn't try to resolve but we can
actually get much closer together
if we focus on individual details in
fact i guess that's the tricky thing
where
it's very common that you will have a
case
that starts with what appears to be a
decision
or a conflict between some broader
values about how society or an economy
or a culture should operate
and by the time it gets to either the
initial court decision or even on an
appeal
some subsequent court's decision it ends
up being
something very very narrow and i think
to some degree that is a source of
frustration for many people
who would like to have these broader
issues resolved sort of like once and
for all
and it doesn't happen because the courts
end up very narrowly making
making a decision as you point out how
should the broader
questions be be dealt with because when
they're dealt with
so-called democratically either by by
you know a ballot initiative or by the
legislatures that we elect
um often it's still not permanent in
that
then it's undone uh at the next
opportunity i mean like how should a
society deal with the broader question
well the the broader questions of values
conflicts i think the first thing i'll
say is they shouldn't be resolved by
courts
okay and and this is the this is
rights conflicts are ultimately
political conflicts or conflicts between
people who have fundamental
disagreements with one another
and it's okay to have fundamental
disagreements with one another that's
what makes us
um human and in some ways the core of
the book is to say look the reason we
we disagree about rights is not because
one of us
is right and the other is wrong because
some of us are angels and others devils
because we're different
people we have different values
different commitments and
when you when you overlay a legal system
onto that kind of disagreement
the legal system has to figure out
how do you construct rules that enable
people to live together
and to stay invested within the
constitutional system so i actually
celebrate
uncertainty at least to a degree i
celebrate
not resolving rights conflicts for all
time because that
that that means that the constitution
doesn't protect or doesn't care about
one or the other side of really
important values conflicts
i don't think that's the way a legal
system should operate i think you try to
mediate those
conflicts through politics and when i
say politics i don't always mean
legislative politics or ballot
initiatives
i mean other kinds of institutions
journalists are
are engaged in in acts of politics when
we go to
when we have you know social media
conversation that's
politics um schools are engaged in forms
of politics politics is
is uh is is constructing a political
culture
a culture of understanding um
what the core of our disagreements might
be understanding the perspective
of other sides and trying to work
towards a solution um that's what
that's what political negotiation looks
like
and that that again that doesn't
necessarily happen
in legislatures although that's the sort
of ultimate
uh that's the ultimate you know power
um wielder is the legislature but before
you get to the legislature there's a
whole lot of political conversation that
has to happen
that gets shut off if we think that the
way to resolve our political conflicts
is to give them to courts who are going
to make kind of legalistic abstract
decisions that don't get us very far to
addressing our conflicts
last thing i want to ask about you know
during the run up to the 2020 election i
received a lot of emails from viewers
and listeners particularly in europe who
said you know i'm following this
election in the united states
and i'm struck by how much talk there is
of people asserting rights
the discussion of my right to free
speech my right to vote my right to a
gun etc
saying that in in their countries this
idea of asserting rights just is not
uh it's not a narrative in elections and
that they found that there was
they were curious about like how did
this become such a thing in american
politics where people are
constantly talking about rights and
asserting rights is there some
particular history to that in the united
states that we can point to about how
this issue of
the asserting of rights became such a
political discussion that in other
countries it simply is not
so so i'll say a couple of things so one
is is
that in in europe they do care about
rights but they just don't
necessarily think of rights as kind of
trumps that kind of
overcome everything else and that's
what's really i think different about
our political culture
and i i think that i try to tell the
story in the
in the book and kind of the first third
of the book uh it doesn't come from the
founding which is what we often tell
ourselves the founders
had a much more communitarian view of
rights than
uh than modern americans do it really
comes out of the 1960s in the post-civil
rights era legacy
and it's a it's a it's a complex story
but what it boils down to
is is a history with race and
with the particular pathologies the
particular problem
of of people who are being racially
discriminated against in overt
ways being kind of the paradigm of
rights
in america right the the the core right
is the right against racial
discrimination
and that's not something you mediate
right that's not something where you say
well
you know let's see what the
segregationists think and then we'll
kind of see what the
other people think it doesn't lend
itself to mediation because one side of
that dispute
is completely bad faith oppressive um
abusive um actor but you can't
dissociate
all of government with you know anytime
my right is at stake that means the
government's being abusive or oppressive
um that's not most rights um that's not
most rights conflicts and so
i think we need a language in which we
can talk about ordinary political
conflict
that doesn't take the form of this is
let's see if this is just like jim crow
or let's see if this is just like
mccarthyism we've got to take
rights conflicts on their facts and
actually think about what the
government's trying to accomplish
and whether it's something that is
considered to be legitimate within our
tradition
very uh very well said uh the book as
we've been uh
mentioning is how rights went wrong why
our obsession with rights is tearing
america apart
we've been uh talking with the author of
the book
professor jamal green it's so great to
have you on i really appreciate your
time
great to be here i enjoyed the
conversation thanks